So we're already seeing it.
It's about to get much worse.
There is going to be a corona virus vaccine,
disinformation war that is going to make the
measles vaccine disinformation seem like child's
child's play.
And we're already seeing it.
Bill Gates, conspiracy theories, conspiracy
conspiracy theories that the Corona virus
itself was a manmade plan to create a pretext
to give everybody a vaccine.
So you can, you know, insert your conspiracy
theory, sterilization, population control,
whatever.
I'm not going to give you every example.
But we've seen it all.
And we now have, as I told you earlier, very
encouraging developments on a number of new
vaccines and most recently from Maidana Maduna
announcing in an early trial of their vaccine,
everybody who got the vaccine generated antibodies
at or greater than the level that a natural
corona virus recovery generates.
Phase three set to start in July.
All good news, but meanwhile, the Corona virus
vaccine disinformation war is already scaling
up before we get the vaccine.
We are going to have virally spreading propaganda
about the vaccine.
There's the stuff in that bogus documentary
pandemic from a couple of weeks ago.
You've got a lot of pseudo science around
coronavirus already.
5 G conspiracy theories tied to Corona virus.
You've got the president wondering about injecting
bleach and Lysol.
Dr. Foushee pulled into all sorts of conspiracies
and on and on and on.
And there's a really good piece in The New
York Times by Kevin Roots, which suggests
this is just the beginning of the propaganda
fight around the Corona virus vaccine.
He says there will be a very loud movement
that is going to try to convince the public
that the eventual corona virus vaccine or
vaccines are dangerous, they are lethal, they
are bad for you.
They are a menace.
They are part of all sorts.
Of horrible conspiracies involving governments
or elites or Bill Gates or whoever, and the
important thing to understand is that they
only need to convince some people to potentially
prevent herd immunity.
And they only need to convince some people
to create absolute havoc.
Just look at what they've done with measles
and the outbreaks that have been caused over
the last few years.
We know that this is going to happen particularly
because of the urgency of this vaccine.
So we know we may have shortened observation
period surveillance periods for people who
have received the vaccine, and we would do
that safely in the sense that it would be
done with vaccines already proven to be safe.
The question would be, well, normally you
might want to confirm that the vaccine gives
you immunity for a year after six months.
We might say, listen, it gives six months
of immunity.
Let's start giving it to people.
That is going to be used by the anti-vaxxers
to argue it's not been tested.
The testing has been short circuited.
It's short circuited as a wild experiment.
So that's one layer that we can expect.
Number two, we know that to really produce
the vaccine at scale and get to billions of
doses.
Organizations like the Bill and Melinda Gates
Foundation will almost certainly have to be
involved.
They are already the targets of anti-vaccine
activists and they've been the targets for
a long time.
Sometimes it's Bill Gates wants to profit
from the vaccine.
Sometimes it's Bill Gates wants to control
the population with a vaccine.
And then number three is Kevin Ruths points
out we might have a period after the vaccine
is available where airlines might say, listen
to fly with us, you need a certificate of
vaccination.
This would not be a government government
mandated vaccine.
It would be a private company like JetBlue
might say.
Our rule is for safety.
We require a vaccine certificate.
This will explode in the anti-vax movement
because mandatory vaccination has been one
of their talking points for a long time.
Now, of course, vaccination, if you want to
fly Jet Blue is very different than the government
is forcing everybody to get a vaccine.
So the point is this is going to be a fight
and it's going to go beyond the normal recesses
of the Internet.
You know, we're used to natural medicine,
Web sites and this sort of thing doing anti-vax
stuff.
But my prediction is that the Corona virus
anti-vax propaganda is going to have wider
distribution than just those on claims on
the Internet.
So what we need to do and what Kevin Roosts
says in his New York Times article needs to
happen is that the pro-vaccine movement, which
we call science and medicine needs to mobilize.
Now, science about vaccines needs to be disseminated.
And in our system, being proactive is rarely
rewarded.
Being proactive is rarely done.
So I'm skeptical that there will be any such
coherent effort.
But it's important that it be done and we're
going to continue doing it.
Hey, Monday, we've got a huge Memorial Day
membership special.
The show is going to be off on Memorial Day,
what with Corona virus, since we're all just
stuck at home.
We've not had an off day for something like
four months or so or even longer.
We are taking Monday off.
We are going to do a one day Memorial Day
membership special.
It's going to be an unconscionable discount.
Attorneys general are beating down my door
saying, David, don't do it.
It's too big of a discount, but we're gonna
do it anyway.
To be notified about this great membership
discount on my Monday, Memorial Day.
Just get on our mailing list.
Sign up for the mailing list at David Pakman
dot com.
We'll take a quick break.
Let me know what you think about the vaccine
trials and propaganda on Twitter where you
can find me at Deepak's The David Pakman Show
at David Pakman dot com.